tous notre troisième écomusée de la
semaine est en fait un musée vivant
thématique celui de l'apiculture
gâtinaise alors c'est une exploitations
apicoles sur lequel est implanté un
centre d'interprétation sur le miel et
c'est aussi un lieu ressource pour la
compréhension du territoire alentours le
territoire du gâtinais que je vous
propose de découvrir grâce à notre carte
postale du jour le bourg de
châteaurenard se trouve au nord-est de
la région en bordure de l'hymne français
de la bourgogne
il se situe à proximité immédiate de
montargis distants d'une petite
vingtaine de kilomètres est presque à
équidistance un peu plus de 50
kilomètres de la ville de sens dans
l'yonne ou de celle de nemours en
seine-et-marne le gâtinais un territoire
partagé entre le loiret l'yonne la
seine-et-marne et même l'essonne un lieu
d'échangés commerciaux et de
transhumance entre paris et l'est de la
france
irrigué par la fameuse nationale 7 et
par deux autoroutes l'a19 et l'a77 une
terre d'agriculture essentiellement
céréalière mais moins riche que la
beauce où l'on a toujours diversifier
les productions l'apiculture y est une
activité connue depuis le moyen-âge et
développé au 19e siècle il y à 100 ans
le miel du gâtinais était le plus
consommé par les parisiens aujourd'hui
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs miel
de plaine en france le miel du gâtinais
que produit notamment l'apiculteur
jacques goût qui est aussi le créateur
de cet écomusée ici à châteaurenard miel
et gastines et font bon ménage depuis
longtemps plusieurs siècles qu'est ce
qui explique finalement ce mariage a
c'est une longue tradition dont nous
sommes fiers en gâtinais est fier de
ceux qui nous ont précédé le mariage
nous incite un petit peu de modestie
parce que c'est la proximité de paris
paris qui a imposé les modes qui
continue d'ailleurs de les imposer
encore au 21ème siècle qui a rendu
célèbre le miel du gâtinais mais si la
notoriété des miels du gâtinais s'était
imposé c'est parce qu'ils étaient de
qualité alors autrefois il était fait à
partir des fleurs de sainfoin trèfle
incarnat la flore a un peu évolué
puisque les tracteurs aujourd'hui sont
nourris au diesel plutôt que les cinq
points qui nourrissait les chevaux il ya
une évolution des on continue de faire
du mondial dans la gatinais et nous nous
inscrire dans cette tradition
tout à fait et pour parler à la fois du
gâtinais probablement un peu du miel
mais surtout ducati nous sommes allé ce
matin
et bien tout simplement sur le marché de
châteaurenard et nous avons écouté les
habitants nous parler de leur territoire
sur l'univers dc je suis parti
travailler un peu plus loin à un moment
donné je suis revenu ici parce que au
final on les trouve à peu près tous
couvre on est à 20 km de montargis 20
km2 charny 20 km de châtillon coligny
on a ce qu'il faut peut-être le désert
médical mais ça je crois que c'est dans
toute la france au niveau tranquillité
mais très bien des gens bonne ambiance
dans les petits villages on a une bonne
ambiance
par rapport à la ville où ça se bagarre
toujours un petit peu j'ai vraiment la
nostalgie 10 à 30 ou 40 ans quoi du tout
pareil c'était plus vivants
économiquement sans doute bruit puis la
mentalité des gens a complètement changé
maintenant plus personne ne se connaît
pratiquement rien des rounds à vue de
saint germain il ya un boulanger ils ont
monté un petit commerce d'alimentation
gp en train de sa lancée et un tabac wa
al ahly nous avons des questions
montargis jeu franchement j'ai changé du
tout au tout et c'est qu'à me qualité de
vie est bien meilleur pour les enfants
et pour nous alors jagot est il est
facile de vivre ici dans ce cas tinée du
xxième siècle comme partout vous êtes
dire que ce serait difficile sera
excessif moi je suis heureux de vivre
sur certains territoires gâtinais ont
comme toutes les régions rurales de
france
la vigne est pas si facile vous êtes
promenés aujourd'hui dans châteaurenard
vous avez vu comme dans beaucoup de nos
villages des boutiques fermées mais il
ya aussi un dynamisme il ya une vie
associative qui est riche et ceux qui
aiment ce territoire ils sont nombreux
arrive à le faire vivre
alors on peut aussi aimer ce territoire
à cause grâce à sa biodiversité
c'est une biodiversité qui vous permet
de vivre vous apiculteurs il faut la
défendre aujourd'hui elle est en danger
ou préservés alors elle est en danger
mais elle n'est pas en russie a touché
qu'on le dit parfois souvent on fait une
caricature en disant que la biodiversité
terriblement en danger dans nos
campagnes
or sur notre territoire gâtinais sur
note gâtinais de l'est on a quand même
encore une surface boisée importante on
a dévalé des rivières on a des étangs et
on a une diversité en entrant la
régulièrement les visiteurs me disent
tiens on a vu beaucoup de papillon chez
vous ça me fait plaisir et ça leur fait
plaisir
et moi je vois sur les champs de fleurs
encore énormément aussi d'abeilles
sauvages
à côté des abeilles que nous élevons et
là c'était un plaisir c'est une richesse
merci jacques gounou demain nous serons
en eure-et-loir à la ferté vilnai y est
nous serons à l'écomusée de la vallée de
l'aigre